This is a physical manifestation of love.
This is glorious and beautiful and any
God, which denies me for this going out,
but part of it,
okay,
on the left hand side,
can I have my LGBT folks on the right
hand side and I have my concerns.
There are times when I feel uncomfortable
expressing my views around sexuality.
Yeah.
I am uncomfortable primarily
because the bromance of like,
well there's two girls who's the boy and
then it really just breaks the ice as
it's like there isn't supposed to
be a boy. That's why we're there.
I do my best to break the ice with the
comedic deflection, which I've learned is,
is a self defense mechanism.
Right.
So I come from a very
serving of community and so, you
know, it just wasn't talked about.
The people I've had the most conversation
with about actually my family,
which is really weird cause I came out
to my parents because my dad was going to
be leading the protests at
the pride festival that my
boyfriend want me to go to.
So I'm a, I'm a pastor as well. Um,
I'm also a community leader and Boyle
heights and in that community there is a
large, um, LGBTQ presence.
So there's that fear of really coming
out and say what I believe because I do
love everybody and I don't want to be
pushed to the side just because I have a
certain feeling about any topic really.
I just wanted to say too,
and you know,
it's not the beliefs that sometimes
I have a problem with her.
I think people have a problem with in
China it's just like the actions from the
belief,
so like it's okay to have beliefs,
but if we like can be loving and our
beliefs and you know how our actions come
from those beliefs and like I love that
we're having this conversation, you know,
like trying to breach those,
like build a bridge.
Some sins are worse than others.
Okay.
In the eyes of, you know,
of the God I worship,
I believe that any sin separates us
from him because he's holy and pure.
But at the same time I think there are
certain sins that will have greater
consequences. I resonate with that.
For me, it would be, you know,
killing another human is the worst.
That's it.
Also it Venn diagrams into abortion.
Taking the life of another is huge,
is huge.
Can I ask you to this, uh, do you
all see homosexuality as a sin?
Yes. And if so, where on that
scale, I don't think I'm, uh,
homosexual tendency or an attraction to
somebody of the same gender is a sin.
Um, I think that's a natural feeling.
I think when you start engaging, um,
in a lifestyle and you act upon that
tendency then because it goes against what
I believe God designed, then I,
I think that's clearly a sin.
I just don't believe in sin because I
feel that sometimes being punitive about
things can like make you repress things
and like instinctually I was like,
but not acting on them would be a thin,
like that's how it feels for me.
Like being dishonest to
myself at that feels wrong.
At some point in my life I
was taught that sex is wrong.
Okay.
I guess like within the
context, uh, you know,
sex is bad outside the
context of marriage. Um,
and so I guess that's how
identified with the question.
Oh,
I had a very strong religious upbringing
and I ended up doing a lot of self harm
and I ended up doing a lot of things just
to try and cope with these urges that
when I finally gave
into them, oh, this is,
this is a physical manifestation of love.
This is glorious and
beautiful and any God,
which denies me for this I
don't want have a part of,
because whatever this is is I know for
a fact to be a truth because it is the
nature of love.
Yeah. I'm just responding
to your story. Uh,
it makes me sad to hear that, um,
that you decided to hurt yourself.
Um,
yeah,
I still hold on to what
I believe are my beliefs,
but at the same time,
I wish there was a better way for you
to talk to someone and to process and to
think through, um, reconciling
how you feel with like,
what you may have been taught
or have read through scripture.
Yeah, I mean, and that's the
thing is I think there's a lot of,
there's a lot of cultural baggage I
think around Christianity that isn't
necessarily inherently part
of any biblical Christianity.
Even though I grew up in
a Christian family, I was,
I don't recall ever being told that
sex was wrong or it was a bad thing.
Um, I think I, I grew up
with the understanding that
sex is a beautiful thing.
It was given to us as a gift to enjoy.
There's a place where it's,
it's been designed for a place where we
can enjoy it and there's a place where
it's, it's the testable in
the side of the creator,
the one who gave it to us.
I just don't like the idea.
Yeah. That anything's really
detestable, you know what I mean? So I,
I just don't like it. You see that even
in sex for you within certain context is,
is testable.
Like,
like if it's nonconsensual like that's
pretty detestable. Yeah, I agree.
Even in that,
the things that I can
send to are,
I think,
not that like at that I have sometimes no
control over it. If it's not consented,
people should honor the pronouns
others wish to be called.
Oh,
hesitations enough.
I'm all for this. Like I identify
as gay people don't consider it.
And I think that like having these
conversations about how people want to
identify is like really important in a
way that we can move things forward and
stuff.
Yeah. I forgot to like, hey, if
you don't use right, whatever,
you're gonna get fined or
whatever. Like that's, I, I'm,
I'm not a big fan of that or
conversations between us, but yeah.
But otherwise it's just being
respectful. Oh, the Pronoun Police.
So for me,
um,
I never correct people because many
times people do confuse me as sir.
I don't know. It doesn't faze me. However,
I'm born in a female body. I'm a sheet.
There are times where my
girlfriends, oh, my boyfriend,
isn't that just because
of their comfort zone.
They don't want to have to deal
with the whole like social stigma.
So you're comfortable with them
presenting you as a, as a male.
It doesn't faze me.
It doesn't phase me at all because my
identity and my expressions are masculine.
And I've come to the terms
in the realization that I
don't need to chop up my
body and the different pieces to fit
in a social little box. That is, man,
if you want to address me you can address
me as he or she or them are girl Becky
with the good hair. It doesn't as
long as the term is respectful.
Yeah, I will take it. Uh,
I'm an ice tea bag just because it's a
complicated topic because with language,
language is powerful.
And so when somebody who I would consider
a female wants to be called a a male,
I would want to probably respect that.
But um, I still firmly believe that,
you know, they're like God created
there to be men and a woman and um,
I would like to sit down and talk to that
person in depth before leaning one way
or the other.
Yeah.
And I think like focusing more on like
building a relationship instead of just
like grilling some, why do you feel,
you know what I mean? Like just try it.
What's wrong with you? Like, why
America is heading in the right
direction when it comes to inclusion and
diversity.
Okay.
Uh,
for me it's more like the youth are
headed in like inclusion and diversity.
And I wouldn't necessarily say
it's the institutions of power.
I think the youth are really moving
our culture forward and like it's
encouraging to see,
I can't imagine what it's like to not be
able to be who I am and having to hide.
So I think it's good in that sense
that people finally are living in a,
in a world where I can be who I am and
I don't have to be ostracized and I can
be included. And the reason why I
didn't step in is because, um, you know,
I have certain values of
that I think are from God.
And so that's why I hesitated a little
bit on do I come forward or not? But,
well I have a question cause I,
you know,
I'm curious where the sanctity
of your marriage comes in.
Like if you can only get married to wound
because you and God and. Dot. Woman,
how about relationship that is perfect
for you. I'm curious how that affects,
uh,
who we can marry.
Yeah.
I don't think the job of a Christian,
for example,
um,
is to get people to behave in a certain
moral way that's in line with what the
Bible says. I wouldn't be
wanting to say you can't marry,
you can't marry another guy or you
can't marry another girl. I would say,
first of all, God loves you. You
know, God loves you. Yeah. So, uh,
specifically talking about like
propping, um, when properly came out,
I was completely against it.
I thought it was foolish and ignorant
and in by many churches supporting prop
eight,
we basically tell you,
told the gay community that
we don't care about you.
We don't care about how you feel,
what you think love is.
We're just going to mandate that you
can't marry who you say you want to marry.
We're adversaries. Yeah.
We became adversaries.
And the church I think lost a great
position and saying and coming to people
saying like,
we love you.
People should have the right to
have sex with anyone. They want
anyone. Okay. Yeah. Alright.
Consensually right. Alright.
Essentially with anyone. I,
okay. Yes. In the term
anyone except children.
Yeah. As humans, we and his
creatures of a divine spirit,
we have the right to follow our instincts
and our sexual urges without punishing
ourselves for, you know,
wanting a woman. You're wanting
a man and so, yeah. And you,
anyone has the right to
consensual love making.
Yeah.
So, um, the, the reason
why I stepped back and,
and you guys would agree with me, but, um,
when I was nine years old, I was
touched by a family member. Bye.
Okay.
And so, you know, if that's,
I can't set forward when,
when that question is asked and,
and I know you guys want to
agree with that and that's you,
you preference of the very beginning that,
you know,
if as long as it's consensual and, and
not kids, but that was my experience
and
yeah,
really sorry about that.
No, I, I resonate with it as well.
I mean, I was as well, you know,
and there wasn't a family member than God.
However,
it's still a enough of a tumultuous
problem that even when I came out as a
lesbian,
I wondered if it had to do with that
incident and definitely brought up and
that's why it was the first thing I said,
you know,
cause you no one is
innocent and doesn't know.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I believe in a higher power.
I'd love to hear it from your
perspective. Oh, why you,
why you believe in a higher power?
I mean the household I was raised in,
why not, uh, the analogy
of like you can't,
one cannot see level one cannot see
air and it's still there and you know,
started going to more clergyman
and wanting to understand.
Exactly. You know, my ways of being
in the image of a greater creator,
understanding I wasn't a mistake.
You know,
cause you know there is a higher source.
There is definitely something that
has given me these blessings that have
nothing to do with me. It has everything
to do with the bigger picture of things.
I think for me, you know, I,
I was also raised in a very strong
religious background and just as I can not
deny this part of me that
was the way I express love.
I'd be dishonest if I said that when I
sat down and I prayed and I listened,
I didn't hear,
oh no,
it's time for the heathen.
You weren't no mistake.
I resonate with some of
the things you said too.
Like I do believe in a higher power.
I just don't believe in
like a typical higher power.
And I also like highly believe in science.
So I'm like,
I believe in gravity as a higher power.
I believe in like entropy is a, you know,
like things that we,
that are out of our control and stuff
and I want to always keep searching and
always cute questioning and like always
trying to find like as much love as
possible I guess. And I believe
in other people's gods too. Yeah.
Like I believe in that for y'all.
You know what I mean?
Like if that's what makes you a better
person and makes you feel more yourself
and feel more love like I believe in that,
you know,
but I can't say that I believe
it for myself cause I, I dunno,
I don't want to cast my all my Eczema.
Yeah guys, thank you friends. Thank you.
Thank you
you guys.
This is Jason from jubilee here.
We hope you enjoyed another
episode of middle ground.
We'd love to hear from
you in the comments below.
Let us know what you
thought about the episode.
Let us know what you thought about the
issue and whether there was someone who
changed your opinion or if there's
something that you agreed with this agreed
with. We'd love to have a great discussion
with you and my comments. As always,
make sure you click here to subscribe
for more videos and we will see you as.